Speaker 1: Let's go let's go
back to Chris from Atlanta,
who says he has fixed his audio. Chris, welcome.
Speaker 6: Thanks, David.
Can you hear me this time?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 6: Wonderful, wonderful. Well,
I was just sitting here, you know, watching
election results and everything. And I was kind
of thinking about the Stacey Abrams race. And I
wanted to get your take on it as far as, you know,
maybe where you think her campaign failed, if
you're that familiar with it, and if you can
maybe compare and contrast, say, her campaign
to a similar one like Beto O'Rourke, you know,
kind of similar matches. They're going up against
incumbent Republicans. And yeah, I know where
this and where they failed or where they did.
Speaker 1: Well, I don't know that Abrams failed,
per se. I think there were a bunch of different
things going on. One is that Georgia really is
a red state, particularly internally, even though,
you know, Biden won the presidency. Georgia really
is a red state when it comes to their internal
politics. It's difficult to knock off an
incumbent. Governor Kemp, to some degree, resisted
Trump's urges to overturn the election in tow. So
not only did you have I mean, listen, none of the
Trump people were going to vote for Stacey Abrams.
And then in addition, you have Republicans who may
not have been big on Trump, who probably saw Kemp
as like, hey, you know what, he's one of the good
Republicans. Trump asked them for 11,000 votes and
he didn't do it. So so that helped him a little
bit. And I think it was mostly that I mean, I
think Stacey Abrams is a great candidate. And you
could say, well, Stacey Abrams is black. Was there
racism? Was race a factor? She lost by a lot, you
know, so of course, you can't ever eliminate that
as a factor. But I think it's more sort of like
the status quo of Georgia internal politics.
Speaker 6: Right. I mean, race and gender
aside. I mean that's a big a big helped over
overcome in the first place. But from from my
perspective, you know, in Georgia and, you know,
watching the media and everything like that is
as from my perspective, she didn't quite fight
hard enough and was wasn't vocal and out there in
the news cycle enough. You know, I feel like there
she kind of almost fell into the trap of the GOP
where they said, all right, we're just we're going
to bring Herschel and the Herschel Dominator
voters are going to vote for us. You know,
down ballot are for the most part anyway.
Speaker 1: I mean, that happened to Domino.
How much it was an overt strategy.
Speaker 6: Of the GOP. You mean?
Right. Maybe not now. Now strategy like all
together for all their races. But you know,
I think they definitely you know, Stacey and
her campaign had opportunity to get to be more
visible and they just weren't. You know.
Speaker 1: Visibility also depends on
the media's willingness to cover you. You know,
and you're right that the Walker Warnock got
a lot more oxygen and we did what we could.
We would regularly cover the race, cover
her debate, cover the disaster of Brian
Kemp. But part of that is also the idea.
Speaker 6: By similar debate. So I mean,
you make your own news.
Speaker 1: You do to some.
Speaker 6: Degree out there. You have
to we have to get out there and listen.
Speaker 1: I think she's great.
I think she's great. And sadly.
Speaker 6: Senator.
Speaker 1: Didn't prevail.
Speaker 6: Yeah. So.
Speaker 1: All right. My friend
Chris from Atlanta, great to hear from you. Great
to hear from everybody who I was able to speak to
today. We're going to take a quick break and I
promise you, we are going to take calls again